We have one of those big if true type of announcements
yesterday, President Joe Biden announced that
there will be enough vaccine supply for every
adult in the United States to get a coronavirus
vaccine by the end of May.
Now, there will be enough supply and we will
have the resources to inject every dose or
two different things.
But we'll talk about that.
Let's look at the announcement from Joe Biden
made yesterday afternoon.
Means we're now on track to have enough vaccine
supply for every adult in America by the end
of May.
Let me say that again.
When we came into office, the prior administration
had contracted for not nearly enough vaccine
to cover adults in America.
We rectified that about three weeks ago.
We were able to say that we'll have enough
vaccine supply for adults by the end of July.
I'm pleased to announce today, as a consequence
of the stepped up process that I've ordered
and just outlined, this country will have
enough vaccine supply a say again for every
adult in America by the end of May, by the
end of May.
That's progress.
Important progress, but it's not enough to
have the vaccine supply.
We need vaccinators, people to put the shots
in people's arms.
So what exactly does this mean?
There will be enough vaccine doses for every
adult to get vaccinated.
Is this possible?
Is it an overpromise?
There's a number of different considerations
here.
And let's just kind of think it through, apply
the sniff test to it.
First of all, remember that right now every
American is mostly every adult.
Two of the vaccines are for 18 plus currently
authorized for 18 years of age and older individuals.
The other is for 16 plus.
So roughly when we say every American right
now, we mean every eligible American, which
is somewhere between 260 and 266.
Let's call it 265 million people if we start
with those eligible age wise for the vaccine.
So we're starting with 265.
Then we look at as of today, March 3rd, what
is the number of people who are vaccinated?
In other words, we start with the 265.
How many are all set and we can remove from
that?
Well, 26 million people got both doses.
So that drops us from 265 to 239 million eligible
Americans left to vaccinate.
Of the 239 million that are left, an additional
25 and a half, 26 million have one dose from
the vaccines that need two doses.
So we need to get those 26 million people
to 100 percent vaccination.
We need another 26 million doses.
So then we will have two hundred and thirteen
million people left to vaccinate in the remainder
of March, April and May, 213 million people
in what is roughly 89 days.
That's a big stretch, but there is more considerations
here.
Joe Biden is saying not that we will vaccinate
every eligible American by the end of May.
He's saying we will have enough vaccines by
the end of May and it could take time from
vaccine availability to actual injection.
So that's one aspect of this.
We also have to probably take off the top
that right now about 25 percent of adults
don't want the vaccine.
That's the latest number.
It's been declining over time.
More and more people want the vaccine over
time.
But in reality, it's not really two hundred
and thirteen million people left to vaccinate.
It's more like one hundred ninety eight million
when you account for those who as of right
now say that they don't want it.
So the question becomes, will there be doses
for one hundred and ninety eight million people
to be vaccinated by the end of May, even if
it takes them a little longer to get vaccinated?
In theory, yes.
It's not crazy to think that that's a number
that's going to be available.
Moderna and Fizer continue to say they will
deliver enough together to cover 200 million
Americans by the end of May.
That would be 400 million doses, but that
includes December, January, February.
It includes what they've already done.
And then Johnson and Johnson, the recently
approved third vaccine, which is a one dose
vaccine.
They had contracted to deliver 87 million
vaccines by the end of May.
Remember, with being one dose.
Eighty seven million vaccines is enough for
87 million people.
But it looks like JNJ is going to fall short.
But there are some breathing room.
Even if Johnson and Johnson does only a part
of the 87 million they contracted to do, it's
quite plausible that you will have enough
vaccines for every eligible American who wants
a vaccine by the end of May.
As I said earlier this week, every indication,
if you look at both what the Biden administration
is claiming and what the pharmaceutical companies
are claiming, every indication is that the
challenge as we get into April and certainly
it may even start to be a challenge in March,
certainly by the end of April and definitively
by May, the challenge will be, do we have
enough infrastructure to put the vaccines
into arms?
Because the amount of new doses we're going
to have in the next 80 days, even in the next
40 days, is well beyond what we currently
are able to inject.
We're going to need more vaccination sites
which are being launched.
We're going to need more vaccinators who are
being hired.
And we may be needing to run some of these
larger vaccination sites 24/7 to make this
happen.
Having enough vaccines by May 31st is great.
If you can't actually inject them for four
months, then it's sort of like, well, it's
actually going to be four more months.
Now, one important thing to know, and this
may increase the number of people that want
the vaccine.
The CDC is expected to announce tomorrow,
Thursday, March 4th, that it's OK.
They're going to give a go ahead for vaccinated
people to gather indoors in small groups without
masks.
This may encourage more people to want the
vaccine and it may lower the vaccine hesitancy.
Remember, at one point sixty percent didn't
want the vaccine.
That was down to 50, 40, 33.
Now it's down to about 25.
The CDC saying, hey, we've determined these
vaccines are effective enough that vaccinated
people, groups of exclusively vaccinated people,
small groups indoors without masks are OK.
That will likely encourage more people to
say, I want the vaccine.
Now, at the same time, the counter would be,
if you care what the CDC says, you probably
already want the vaccine.
You're already in the group of people that
want it.
So maybe it won't make that big of a difference.
I don't know if the CDC is going to convince
too many anti vaccines that at this late stage
still don't want the vaccine.
But it's something people who have been fully
vaccinated against covid-19 will be cleared
to gather in small groups without masks.
Dr. Anthony Fauci said yesterday, quote, I
used the example of a doctor coming in from
out of town who is doubly vaccinated and a
husband and wife will be vaccinated and maybe
a next door neighbor who, you know, are vaccinated
small gatherings in the home of people.
I think you can clearly feel that the relative
risk is so low that you would not have to
wear a mask that you could have a good social
gathering within the home.
That is very good news.
That is very optimistic news, and I find it
completely reasonable.
Now, it goes without saying that if this new
vaccine timeline is accurate, we are again,
I want to be realistically optimistic based
on what we're being told.
We are looking at a potentially very good
summer, all else being equal, assuming we
don't have significant variant escape from
the vaccines and all of the things that we're
watching, we're potentially looking at a pretty
solid summer and we will continue to cover
it.